[Music]
so let's have a short intro to a short
video today we will look at a very
strange dinosaur that existed in the
cretaceous period we look at its habitat
its evolutionary lineage why its cousins
are so different from it and what's more
shocking is the kind of dinosaur a
therizinosaurus is
i bet many of you already know
but for the ones that don't let's look
at this creature in detail and describe
whether the jurassic world dominion
version is scientifically correct or not
so let's get to it
the first remains of the teresinosaurus
was found in 1948 by a mongolian field
expedition at the gobi desert in
mongolia
the terrazinosaurus was a large dinosaur
although not as large as the sauropods
or the big carnivores like the t-rex the
giganotosaurus the spinosaurus it's
still a pretty big dino nonetheless
there have been various size and weight
estimates over the years since its
discovery these animals obtain enormous
sizes estimated to be around 9 to 10
meters or 30 to 33 feet long
with weights from 3 tons to possibly
over 5 tons and they also stand almost
upright with its head being 15 to 16
feet above the ground
so when and where that it exists in the
past
as we said earlier the first specimen
was unearthed in mongolia in 1948 but it
was only studied and properly classified
as a species on its own six years later
in 1954
this creature lived in asia during the
late cretaceous period in what is now
the nemec formation around 70 million
years ago this geological formation is
primarily in the gobi desert of mongolia
so being from that age in that place it
would have been around many large
predators with the main enemy of it
being the toposaurus bataar a close
cousin of the t-rex of north america
so what kind of dinosaur is it really
well in the bbc documentary planet
dinosaur it was stated to be a cousin of
the tyrannosaurus but a lot of time has
passed since that and it is now placed
in a separate super family which is just
terry xenosauridae it is although a
theropod dinosaur but the only relation
it had to the t-rex was that it was a
coelasaur
although being a theropod it wasn't a
carnivore and over the millions of years
this creature developed and evolved
traits that made it more suitable to be
a plant eater a herbivore it had a long
neck similar to the triassic plateau
service
it had also a big like mouth but with a
blunt and slightly serrated teeth which
confirmed that it was in fact a
herbivore
so what is its characteristic feature
that really stands out
well it could flip the ultimate bird if
it was angry the therizinosaurus had
huge arms that could grow to be around 8
feet long or 2.4 meters
and on the tip of its hands are three
huge claws with the largest estimates
putting them the claws at over five feet
long or 1.5 meters but that's an
overstatement the largest they could
grow to would be less than one meter or
three feet long but that's still
terrifying
these large claws are mainly for defense
and foraging they could be used to hook
and pull down branches as they forage
and they could also use to swipe at
predators for protection against mainly
their turbosaurus and other carnivores
and maybe for fights over mates and
territory
so one question that many of you might
have is if it was a theropod dancer then
why did it change from being a predator
into a plan either essentially a prey
this is something of a mystery but just
as many species evolve over time to
become something way different the same
could be said about this dinosaur its
ancestors would have probably been
carnivorous theropods but somewhere down
the line a series of distinct mutations
occurred that made a certain population
of these ancestral therizinosaurs
into omnivores and being able to digest
plants and meat at the same time this
might have made them more successful in
driving and populating the environment
around them and then over millions of
years they gradually lost their
predatory traits and the ones with
herbivore characteristics dominated and
became the species therizinosaurus
chiloniformers but that's still a theory
now let's have a comparison between the
jurassic world dominion version and the
real life version of this dinosaur well
the dominion version has a size of 5 to
6 meters in height which means around 16
to 20 feet tall a length of 9 to 12
meters or 30 to 40 feet long and a
weight of 6 tons the real life version
on the other hand is slightly smaller
standing at 45 meters or 13 to 16 feet
tall a length of 9 to 10 meters or 30 to
33 feet long and a weight of between
three to five tons so as we can see the
jurassic world version is bigger but not
by much
most of the other traits however are
identical such as being covered in
sparse feathers having a big leg mouth
with teeth and a long neck as well as
being territorial and herbivore and
having those huge ass claws so yeah
that's all good
fun fact before we end this the
teresinosaurus was subject to a lot of
confusion as to how it looked like it
was originally thought to be a marine
turtle but with the discovery of the
notre nyquis a related species its
appearance was settled
then later
it was said to be a cousin of the t-rex
a tyrannosaur but we now know that its
only connection to the tyrant lizard
king the tyrannosaurus rex was that they
were both tequila saws
a subgroup of theropod dinosaurs that
include the comsoc methods the
tyrannosaurus the auto memosaurs and the
many rap torrents anyway with that we
come to the end of it so do hit that
like button for support and subscribe to
be a part of the minecube family but
most of all smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam